[Música]
pasamos ahora hablar entonces como lo
decíamos previamente con nuestro primer
invitado del día sobre lo que fue esta
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales francesas que iba a pasar
hacia dónde van los candidatos y cómo
quedó todo vamos a analizarlo con
rodrigo murillo el historiador analista
internacional y politólogo rodrigo
gracias por estar con nosotros una vez
más en directo américa de france 24 ya
muy buena tarde para ustedes rodrigo
buenos días un placer acompañarle
gracias por invitarme pues le queremos
ser preguntando entonces que esperar
esta segunda vuelta la repetición del
duelo como también hablamos con rosa
pero además de eeuu de lo que fue el año
2017 cuando macrón le ganó al epen que
pasara se repetirá esto o pues peligra
la repetición del candidato presidente
manel macrón bueno en principio quisiera
decir que ha sido una elección cuyos
resultados confirman una tendencia creo
yo de amplitud histórica los dos grandes
baluartes de la política francesa los
republicanos y el partido socialista han
obtenido peores resultados que los ya de
por sí nefastos resultados que
obtuvieron en el 2017 y la preferencia
del electorado lejos de concentrarse en
organizaciones sólidas que canalizaban
anteriormente la participación política
opta hoy en día por los personalismos y
con ellos como hemos visto anoche se ha
aclarado el panorama este 24 de abril
por un lado el populismo que suele
surgir
en torno a los extremos políticos hará
frente a esa suerte de voto útil de voto
estratégico que pretende evitar en esta
segunda vuelta que el populismo llegue
al poder según mi juicio ese voto
utilitario da vida y muchas
probabilidades a emanuel macrón y
precisamente hablando de voto útil no
como comentaba este voto para impedir
que la extrema derecha llegue al elíseo
veíamos en la prensa como pues se
criticaba un poco que durante este
mandato de manuel macro el mandatario de
francia durante los últimos cinco años
haya atacado a sectores que ahora
necesitan no precisamente para hacer
esta barrera que dificultades que
diferencias puede haber ahora respecto a
2017 en esta segunda vuelta
las dificultades son impresionantes e
importantes y en principio porque
estamos ante un candidato o como una
chrome que tiene amplias posibilidades
de ganar pero que sin embargo
prácticamente no hizo campaña alguna y
esto bueno él argumenta que estaba pues
ocupado por la crisis internacional a
klaus que se vive entre rusia y ucrania
es agresión atroz él argumenta que por
este motivo pues no pudo hacer campaña
pero yo pienso que esta actitud que
algunos en francia catalogan de
estratégica pues al apostar a lo
benefició por un lado evitó que los
restantes candidatos de la elección
pudiesen tener un debate democrático con
el que hubiese servido ante todo a los
electores y por otro creo también yo
habida cuenta que el conflicto entre
rusia y ucrania se ha prolongado y los
precios en frase en francia comienzan a
evitar en consecuencia ha generado que
los populismos tanto de derecha como
izquierda hayan crecido de manera
sumamente importante al extremo de qué
si la elección era una semana o dos
semanas más tarde quizás no estaría de
manuel macro ni la figura sino más bien
jean luc mélenchon imagine le pain sí
además precisamente eso rodrigo de qué
lectura le podemos hacer entonces a lo
que ocurrió con mélenchon se quedó una
vez más fuera de esta segunda vuelta
electoral ya creo que por tercera vez
pero digamos que igual tuvo más votos
que los que tuvo en el 2017 dice no
votar por le pen a sus electores pero
tampoco le da el apoyo a manuel macrón
que van a pasar qué va a pasar entonces
con estos votos de mención finalmente sí
dirá pues bueno vamos a apoyar a de
manera cordón para lo que hablaba rosa
también estos fotos barrera para evitar
que la extrema derecha
se haga con la presidencia francesa el
24 abril
lo de jean-luc mélenchon en mi opinión
ha sido notable en esta elección él ha
logrado conectar con un electorado de
izquierda que ya prácticamente no tiene
ninguna conexión con el partido
socialista ahora en ese sentido yo creo
que estamos ante un triunfo de jean-luc
mélenchon y probablemente de haber sido
la elección un poco más tarde otro sería
el escenario los franceses suelen ser
contestatarios y no suelen respetar el
endoso de los votos que hacen sus
candidatos corresponde ahora
escuchaba en la mañana esta emisión una
emisión de portavoz de marín le pen que
culminaba a los seguidores de berenson
de ser realmente insumisos de
insubordinarse a esta suerte de endoso
de voto que hizo anoche mélenchon pero
veremos si es que marie le pen puede
conectar con estos votantes muy
importantes una marine lepén que a
diferencia del año 2017 ya no se ha
mostrado ni como una candidata de
derecha ni de izquierda
es el lugar de extrema derecha y le dejo
la izquierda ciertamente hay alguna
lección
simplemente mostrándose como la
candidata soberanista que le habla a la
gente en su idioma y que al plantear
recuperar la soberanía pues de los
franceses les ofrece abiertamente
aliviarles el bolsillo y mejorar su
poder adquisitivo si digamos también
rosa y rodrigo que diga estos partidos
se le facilitaron esta campaña también
como lo hablamos aquí una revista de
prensa rosa a marín le pone una
candidata pues que también uso esto como
estrategia para no hablar de su discurso
de extrema derecha sino de ir a votar ir
a participar y como elx usted rodrigo de
la soberanía rosa claro pero de hecho
ayer a jean-luc menos son precisamente
después de que se conociera ni a las
estimaciones definitivas insistió mucho
e incluso el mismo dijo lo digo lo digo
claro porque después se me atribuyen
cosas que yo nunca he dicho y digamos él
fue muy claro en pedir a sus electores
que no dieran ni un voto a la extrema
derecha por lo que pues
es un poco quizás atrevido con asegurar
que los votantes de la francia insumisa
irán para la extrema derecha de hecho ha
salido que los más jóvenes han votado
ampliamente para gianluca nani son usted
pues como
explica esta relación generacional con
la izquierda está claro que
prácticamente marie le pen tiene una
tarea imposible por delante no conectar
con los votantes de extrema izquierda va
a ser muy complicado para ella a pesar
de la estrategia que creo yo de una
forma medianamente exitosa para cosechar
votos de la derecha digamos moderada
centrista le ha valido este este pequeño
triunfo ahora lo que corresponde es
también poner los ojos de cara a lo que
hará de manuel macro manuel macro no
puede dar por sentada el sur historia en
la segunda vuelta y por el contrario
tiene que hacer en este tipo en este
poco tiempo que le queda la campaña que
no hizo
no solamente aceptar el endoso de estos
votos sino como bien menciona usted
tratar de llegar directamente a los
jóvenes y por qué no mirar las
propuestas de los candidatos que no
pasaron a la segunda vuelta para
incorporar algunas de ellas a su
programa un triunfo de marc inglés sería
sumamente complejo no solamente para la
economía de francia sino para
organizaciones internacionales tan
importantes como la unión europea o la
otan quisiera dejar en claro que emanuel
macrón tiene una gran tarea por delante
y un punto fundamental de esta tarea
desconectar con los jóvenes
independientemente de lo que digan los
líderes de otras tiendas políticas
ahora rodrigo hablemos de otro fenómeno
que ocurrió anoche el colapso completo
de estos partidos tradicionales
republicana parece que crece pidiéndole
también a sus seguidores de su partido
hacer donaciones para que este partido
se mantenga en pie los socialistas
sacaron el 2% menos del 2%
un desastre realmente para este partido
como podemos hacer esa lectura
es bien interesante
antes entendíamos el panorama político
francés en base a dos ejes no es verdad
la izquierda y la derecha me temo que
eso ya quedó obsoleto y lo que tenemos
ahora pueden ser también dos ejes por un
lado tenemos un eje liberal centrista
que recoge algunos elementos de la
izquierda centrista de la derecha
centrista pro unión europea pero está
más bien vinculado con lo políticamente
correcto
digamos lo que es considerado
normalmente algo de buena educación muy
entre comillas y por otro lado tenemos
un bloque soberanista
nacionalista que quiere cambiarlo todo
que quiere quebrar esquemas tan válidos
como por ejemplo la prioridad que tienen
las leyes europeas respecto a algunas
leyes de la república francesa yo creo
que esa es la nueva lectura y si los
partidos no reaccionan a esta nueva
lectura seguiremos dependiendo de
personalismos y caudillismos para
definir estas elecciones vamos a ver
entonces lo que va a pasar sobre todo
este próximo 24 de abril rodrigo gracias
nuevamente por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 un gran
abrazo hasta luego y en casa de gracias